bootleghead podcast we got my guy
gorilla nims in the building we back
he's back for the third third this is
the third time around man yup let's go
man uh we we gotta load up some hot [ __ ]
let's just go really come on
[Music]
yeah
yeah
uh-huh
[ __ ] your life stupid we outside bullet
kev
yo yo
ah i'm outside with the legends and
robbers you out here doing videos and
leggings and joggers
gorilla nims i'm the [ __ ]
hardest from brooklyn to la like the
dodgers remarking now we on the road
doing big shows for dollars after party
at the strip club we dick hold that
swallow you want smoke it'll be a [ __ ]
show i promise bounce your head off the
pavement like a six foe impala
now we moving at the speed of light get
money stay solid and quiet that's the
key to life come to my block whatever
you want for a decent price my shooters
can name every gun but can't read or
write yeah homie i'm really linked in
you a professional dick sucker add that
to your linkedin acts around the hood
they'll tell you i've really been him
and i'll break your [ __ ] jaw like you
had a thin chin come to your block set
up shop then we tie it down package it
up then distribute it either white or
brown coney island is the lavish now
life is style rides ain't the only thing
getting pimped on this side of town yeah
watch your mouth while i blame you joe
i'm half man and half gorilla like a
neanderthal huh
[ __ ] you and your girly face it's
[ __ ] life like god smacks you at the
pearly gates i get money but i always
want to see more
one door closes there goes three more my
life is filled with expensive habits and
cheap halls
last night i was bored broke a fiend's
jaw that ain't just [ __ ] on the gram
homie i know you fronting grown men
failing that life claiming you owe them
something
talking all loud making the whole
production
so disgusting homie there's no
discussion i'll put your face on the
back of a charm if it's beef you'll get
done send bouquets to his mom
yeah i live the life of a dawn you know
[ __ ] when i want rolex on the arm
gorilla names is the wickedest matter of
fact scratch that nims is the most
officialist never seen a lyricist
spitting with this much viciousness i
have my man [ __ ] your girl and give a
syphilis
shove a [ __ ] life so [ __ ]
disrespectful bing bong bing bong what
the syphilis she's gonna need a
penicillin shot ya [ __ ] damn you know
about it i might hey yo i know you just
watched the crazy freestyle we got
another one coming next week presented
to you by lrg don't forget to use my
promo code at
l-r-g.com
go to their website it's in the
description below and use the promo code
bootleg you'll save 30 off and they just
drop these look at these basketball
shorts boys these things is crazy you
know what i'm saying lrg's [ __ ] back
so why don't you go ahead and uh go get
you some 30 off right now